the raiders have a well-documented
commitment to the community and in
particular when it comes to high school
football and today that was on full
display at allegiant stadium 8 sports
now kevin martin has our story
that was breathtaking be honest with you
there is artwork displayed on almost
every single wall in allegiant stadium
and on tuesday the raiders and
intermountain health care unveiled the
newest piece
96 nevada high school football helmets
formed in the shape of the state they
contribute to the great football
environment that we have in the state
and just being able to see it all
visually is very impressive we're very
proud of it and proud of the supporting
the effort of all the individual schools
this display has been in the works for a
while and to finally see it come to
fruition was a bit surreal for liberty's
head football coach rich morocco surreal
because
we as coaches association had talked
about
or kind of wished that the raiders would
do something like this you know to
showcase high school football and i know
there's been a number of hurdles to to
get it up
and in the stadium and we're just really
happy that
they're showing a commitment to high
school football here
former writer chris mclemore played his
high school football here in las vegas
and couldn't help but smile when he
spotted valley high's helmet
just seeing that helmet in the legion
stadium
helmet that i went to high school with
yeah it was it's i have a smile on my
face right now it was exciting kevin
martin 8 sports now